très lourd et parfois en plus de la
teinte respiratoires il ya d'autres
organes qui sont touchés le coeur les
reins le foie et dont quatre mois là le
pronostic vital étant d'autant plus
engagé donc s'est dit fier de donner un
pronostic général puisque tout dépend de
l'âge de la présence ou non de facteurs
de risque et de l'état du patient quand
il arrive en réanimation et vous le
savez les animateurs font beaucoup de
statistiques qui sont très attentifs à
la prise en charge optimale des patients
et donc en général il ya un score de
gravité c'est en fonction de ce score de
gravité que le pronostic est donné à
l'entourage du patient question pour vl
médias l'asm a décidé hier de suspendre
les essais cliniques portant sur le sens
de vers marins qui étaient portés par
l'ap-hp après la révélation d'une étude
aux résultats négatifs sur les ports en
cet essai clinique peut-il reprendre un
petit il reprend dans un autre hôpital
une fois le feu vert la nsm obtenus et
sous quelles conditions quel avis
portent là des jets sur le potentiel de
cette molécule pour traiter les patients
atteints du cerf des alliés à la cause
d'infection koffi 19 alors c'est
effectivement une étude qui avait été
autorisé au départ avec une promotion
assistance publique
c'est une honte un concept intéressant
tu ne voulais qu'une intéressante
puisque c'est un concept de
transporteurs d'oxygène donc pour des
patients qui ont une détresse
respiratoire avoir un transporteurs
d'oxygène peut être utile surtout que
cette transporteur était considéré comme
beaucoup plus puissants que
l'hémoglobine
il y a toujours en france quand on
propose une réglementation qui implique
des personnes humaines des patients 2-2
obligation de l'autorisation
un comité de protection des personnes
qui se réunit qui est une structure
collégiale canalise le risque pour les
personnes à qui on va proposer ce
traitement
et puis l' agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament qui est en charge de la
sécurité des médicaments qui sont
proposés aux patients en france donc il
y a eu ses deux passages l'information
qui est arrivé tardivement à l' agence
du médicament c'est qu'il y avait eu une
étude préclinique il ya plusieurs années
chez des porcs et que ces porcs qui
avait été traité avait une létalité une
mortalité de 100 % quand il avait été
traité
c'était une information on ne disposait
pas lagence donc à la reprit son
autorisation elle a suspendu son
autorisation le temps d'examiner tous
les éléments nouveaux qui lui étaient
soumis et c'est à ce moment là
uniquement qu'elle pourra
prendre la décision de reprendre ou non
l'étude une question pour la paix m
les recommandations hs demandé en
urgence à semaine dernière sur
l'allongement du délai de livraison
était annoncé pour cette semaine
pourtant nous sommes vendredi sont elles
prêtes
est-ce que vous allez mettre en place un
allongement de même pour la réalisation
de consultations nécessaires aux ivg
médicamenteuses sous forme de
téléconsultation à quand les textes
audio alors c'est un sujet très
important pour les femmes donc nous
sommes évidemment très attentifs à la
santé des femmes nous avons cette
décision effectivement d'allonger les vg
médicamenteuse en ville de sept semaines
d'aménorrhée à neuf semaines de
permettre aussi aux femmes de bénéficier
de la téléconsultation ce qui
permettrait que l' ordonnance soit
directement adressé en pharmacie pour
qu'elles puissent directement récupéré
le traitement en pharmacie et donc la
publication du texte est imminente de
questions pour france info pouvez vous
nous donner des précisions sur la
mortalité en ehpad et sur ce qui est
fait pour accompagner ces établissements
dans la gestion de la crise alors vous
savez que le ministre des solidarités de
la santé olivier ferrand a fait de la
prise en charge des ehpad une priorité
majeure d'abord parce que vous savez
nous avons confiné ces établissements
dès le début de l'épidémie
ensuite parce que nous avons ajoutées au
confinement globale de l'établissement
un confinement en chambre qui est
quelque chose de difficile qui est qu
est une méthode qui est une solution qui
a été proposé aux étals sous réserve que
l'organisation de l'ehpad le permettent
sous réserve que les familles et le
personnel et et bien compris
l'importance de cette mesure et que les
les résidents puisse l'accepter puisque
là encore tout dépend d'eux des troubles
éventuellement cognitives de ses
résidents et de leur caractère
déambulant vous savez qu'il ya des
personnes âgées qui ne peuvent pas
rester au même endroit qui ont besoin de
bouger donc tout ça écrit en compte au
plan individuel pour confiner au mieux
les personnes
nous avons aujourd'hui renforcer l'accès
de ces établissements à un avis médical
l'accès de ces établissements à une
filière privilégié en milieu hospitalier
l'accès de ces établissements à des
tests lorsque c'est nécessaire qu'il y
ait un cas suspect au sein du personnel
ou au sein des résidents et puis nous
les aidons ensuite
en termes de renforts en termes de
volontaires en termes de réserve
sanitaire pour permettre la prise en
charge optimale des résidents dans cette
période qui est particulièrement
difficile pour tous les résidents où en
est la montée en puissance rapide du
nombre de tests diagnostiques ducobu 19
annoncé la semaine dernière par le
premier ministre alors nous sommes là
sur les tests virologiques
nous avons acquis une vingtaine
d'automates qui permettent de faire du
séquençage à haut débit nous sommes donc
en train de renforcer sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
l'accès aux tests dans tous les
laboratoires vous savez qu'il ya des
laboratoires de virologie qui sont dans
tous les sites hospitaliers donc
désormais dans l'ensemble des
départements de france il ya un accès à
des laboratoires de virologie nous avons
ouvert aussi l'accès aux tests à des
laboratoires qui n'en faisait pas
jusqu'à maintenant et laboratoire
vétérinaire laboratoires de recherche et
laboratoires de police de gendarmerie
des laboratoires départementaux
donc on ouvre toute la capacité
française de test à cette possibilité
donc renforcé de test pour toutes les
personnes qui en auraient besoin et en
priorité le personnel hospitalier et en
priorité le personnel des ehpad et leurs
résidents une question powell france le
professeur delfraissy a déclaré mercredi
que le taux d'immunité de la population
française au corona virus tourner autour
de 10 à 15%
quelle est la fiabilité des tests
utilisés peut-on avoir plus de détails
sur ces tests sérologiques alors là nous
basculons des tests virologiques qui
recherchent le virus aux tests
sérologiques qui recherchent des
anticorps une immunité
première difficulté ce n'est pas
tellement la qualité du test c'est le
fait comme je voulais dire qu'après une
infection il faut attendre au moins deux
voire trois semaines pour que les
anticorps montant population donc faire
des tests sérologiques pendant que vous
êtes malade n'a pas de sens donc il faut
attendre que les gens soient guéris sois
rentré à la maison et puissent se
développer des anticorps
ensuite il faut qu'on ait accès à ces
sérologique il y a beaucoup de
fabricants de tests et nous le sommes en
train de les homologué ne vérifier la
qualité du test et ensuite donner accès
au laboratoire en particulier
laboratoire d analyse à ces tests qui
sont soit des tests classiques que les
français connaissent
et qui nécessitent une prise de sang
soit des tests rapides qui sont faits
avec une piqûre au bout du doigt et qui
vous donne un résultat beaucoup plus
rapides donc nous avons la capacité en
france de faire des études de
séroprévalence est à lire de voir quelle
est la part de la population qui est
immunisée comme je vous le dis il ya des
études en cours de séroprévalence
parfois grâce à l'établissement français
du sang soit sur des donneurs de sang
qui sont plutôt des personnes très
protégé de la maladie puisqu'ils font
très attention à ne pas être malade
parce que sinon ils ne donnent pas leur
sang mais aussi sur des personnes très
exposée par exemple des volontaires ou
professionnels des hôpitaux d'alsace qui
ont demandé à bénéficier de ce type de
test pour savoir quel était leur niveau
d'immunité donc nous avons de plus en
plus de résultats en population et nous
allons estimé grâce aux modélisations
grâce à la mobilisation des
épidémiologistes quel est le niveau
moyen d'immunité en france en sachant
qu'il est possible qu'ils aient des
différences importantes entre régions
parce que les français le constate jour
après jour des régions sont beaucoup
plus touchés que d'autres
avec un gradient qu'on voit bien de
nord-est au sud-ouest les les dix
régions que j'ai cités en terme de
mortalité sont les dix régions où le
virus a le plus circulé en france avant
ce confinement de questions pour mehdi
site des chercheurs américains test
l'oxydé nitrique contre l' insuffisance
pulmonaire sévère
des tests cliniques sont ils prévus ou
en cours en france alors c'est ce sont
des techniques sont utilisées en
réanimation et effectivement les
réanimateurs français échangent avec les
réanimateurs internationaux que ce soit
les américains ou d'autres collègues
européens pour tester tous les moyens
d'aider des patients en détresse
respiratoire aiguë à passer ce cap
une équipe de l'université de toronto
estime que la distanciation sociale
devrait continuer au moins deux ans cela
pourrait-il être le cas en france
alors je ne donne aucun pronostic sur la
durée nécessaire à cette mesure je pense
que par contre qu'il est important de
dire c'est que tant que le virus circule
tant que l'épidémie n'est pas terminée
tant que nous n'avons pas une immunité
collective importante que nous n'avons
pas de vaccin il faudra effectivement
conserver un certain nombre d'habitudes
que nous avons prises les gestes
barrières seront toujours utile la
distanciation physique sera toujours une
bonne pratique et la réduction des
contacts et une eau indispensable on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a appris
à télétravailler on a appris à être
moins rassemblés dans des dans des
réunions à faire attention un petit peu
au nombre de personnes dans une salle et
ce sont des bonnes pratiques qu'il
faudra probablement encouragés pendant
les prochaines semaines de questions
pour hospimedia les services d'aidé et
de soins à domicile vont devoir assurer
de plus en plus de sorties
d'hospitalisation mais n'ont pas le
matériel de protection nécessaire des
mesures sont elles prévues
oui absolument nous sommes très
attentifs à soutenir ces personnes
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
pour leur donner un accès effectivement
à des matériels de protection parce que
elles vont être absolument à le sont
déjà
elles sauront encore plus indispensable
dans les prochaines semaines quand
beaucoup de personnes nous reviendrons à
domicile
elles font déjà un travail remarquable
jour après jour dans des conditions
complexes on imagine mais effectivement
nous sommes très attentifs à ces
personnels très important si les
craintes d'une recrudescence de
l'épidémie se confirme après ce week end
quelles seront les mesures envisagées
alors il n'y a pas de raison d'avoir une
recrudescence de l'épidémie parce qu'on
nous observons et nous remercions les
françaises et les français de leur bon
respect du confinement et le confinement
quand il est respecté a un impact très
positif sur l'épidémie je vous remercie
ses les dernières questions